гаряча вода нормально і впала не била
просто руб студент 5 курсу кривому
гляньте кулака демі віктор куртки з
коломії
розум із товаришами видів поривала
рівень де квартири
обидва ножі тур теж тку сексу з вусики
харчі вечері у віктора зазвучати просто
у батька вінду папір не простудити піт
рубля та образу на двох роботах його
стипендії для жити old & wise
за малим 900 його ньому нижні вікна ви 100
чаю для того, щоб нормально хочу вати
виплат це за житло доступна в руку
вельможі заглушить з бо з грав за
плану - вигляд і поспішаючи висікти не від тільки
43900 до студентів за мужик про тинду
вати на академічні стипендії улови
наші вони швидше
і середній бал вище четвер і сьом
висотки студентів він прямо в цьому
соціальності по Індії я хочу вимагати
так допоможуть держави кому виплачуватись
степаніді вище в цій каламутні внж в
міністерством і цілувати і віктор
олегович
лісову об'єктивну систему восени не
студентів ну в без 6 про нами вище
україни студентів будуть сука точних ще
зароблю
нині у віктора середній бал четвірка
теж ink jet шакшука ти ноги і підр убитий
кай плескати в полон ще просіть на кліках
роботах служили тася краще
незалежної студентки він і не зайці
протестує проти плану в неї почти нині
стипендії mode в 75 висотки студента у
мета мантуя закон про ви ще у світла як
що президент підпиши за хвилину цілу
закону у хвали не йшов стовбуру дня стапеля
дайте в табір
до 23 сотки менше ми хочемо почати треба
закон накладає, а ще все таких був і
за гарантією початку можемо обвалюватися в
законі за раз вона вся обласного я не
хочу я на краще бц змінилося нічого не
змінило ти неправильно поважають що
студійського самоврядування мух лян кай
вас і новак, а життя менше чекісти
зрозуміти їх мінус vid і pid вище стипендію
середньому
на 45 високих академічно до 1600
гривень суть вони до 1100 вставляйся
панель дак українською що можна бути
обійшов його там ще ну розумієте думати і
дякую за животи шукаємо добрий і залишився до
випарти про ти глобальним і увійти саме
світинне соціально справедливо і ми обидва
знаємо про і буде не економіст за нього
педро хонг а ми обидва студенти особливі
виникли районі не навіювання петр
вугілля ти у ківі виймаєш вранці у видасть
і підемо на менше ніж три тисячі гривень а
ви продовжите реформу тулу на премію
уряд побити а біля ставків трьох доступних
rocky
[музика]